last night the Real Housewives of Orange
County had their Hollywood premiere for
their 11th season and something we're
lucky to be alive because they were in
an accident had to be airlifted to the
hospital a reality expert Brice and ER
got the life and death details this
probably the scariest thing that's ever
happened to me I don't know what
happened other than the fact that we
started rolling I think we're on the
side of a dune going a little too fast
maybe I don't really know while shooting
an episode an ATV driven by Tamra judge
rolled over and crashed Tamra and Vicki
Gunvalson were rushed to the hospital
what started out as like a super fun
amazing time and renews friendships
turned into a near-death experience and
one that I still have nightmares about
oh my god there was a moment there where
you thought this is it ah I mean I
really thought I was going to have it I
mean I really kind of thought I'm hurt
I'm hurt i have heard it was a weird
feeling it was really something special
so I'm glad I'm here I'm glad I'm not
injured and i'm glad i have more like
left